welcome to another thankful thursday i
believe it's important to thank the
people in your life who've had an impact
on your business on your personal life
because you can't do this thing alone
you need people's help and it's great to
once in a while just say
thank you so today i want to thank
random order random order is a band and
they are the music behind my famous
failures that come out on sunday so if
you ever see those videos that have all
the famous people and their early
failures and people who didn't believe
in them and they kept going and they
persevered and they made it the
background track on that for a lot of
the videos is from random order and it's
uh it's a really catchy song too i it
grows them every time i listen to it i
start dancing a little bit more so
random order thank you guys so much for
contributing your music i love it it's
it's such a great new addition to the
videos that we're putting up there uh
and for everybody watching i want to do
a quick shout out because random orders
actually up for a fan favorite award
i'll include the link below that you
guys can go check out and click and uh
go vote for them i already put my vote
in they're on to the next round they
could use a little extra push so go vote
for random order uh and for everybody
watching just take time today to thank
somebody who's had an impact on your
business somehow you know they believe
in you or they give you some advice or
they
put you onto a connection whatever it is
because again you can't do this alone
and taking five minutes to say thank you
if it's a phone call if it's writing an
email making a video whatever it is
you'll feel better they'll feel great
and you're spreading some good karma
which we need more of in this world
believe you guys like this video you
want to see more just like it subscribe
to the channel thank you so much
i'll see you soon and go vote for random
order
if you want the real goods i share my
best advice for entrepreneurs every week
in my newsletter click the link below to
check it out it's free
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
riseonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period